former kidnap victim Elizabeth Smart
describes a surprise decision to free
one of her captors as incomprehensible
smart was rescued back in 2003 after
being taken and held in captivity for
nine months
Wanda bars II will be released next week
after Utah officials determined they
miscalculated her prison sentence bar Z
was convicted in 2010 for her role in
the abduction
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with reaction to
the dramatic change in the sentence I
keep hearing that took many off guard
black good morning it did take a lot of
tumble off guard
good morning Wanda bars II will be
released one week from today more than
five years earlier than expected
smart says she's surprised and
disappointed to learn of the decision
she said she'll publicly speak about
bars ease release in the coming days
after first trying to understand it
sixteen years after surviving
unimaginable Horrors Elizabeth Smart is
still haunted by her abduction 72 year
old Wanda bars II who pleaded guilty to
helping her husband Brian David Mitchell
kidnap smart and hold her hostage will
soon be a free woman by law we have to
release her she served her maximum time
with Utah in 2010 bar Z was convicted of
both federal and state crimes after
completing her federal sentence in 2016
she began serving her state sentence but
in a stunning announcement on Tuesday
the Utah Board of Pardons and Paroles
says it miscalculated her state sentence
now instead of a release in 2024 she'll
go free on September 19th and board must
count her federal time with her sentence
in a statement smart said in part it is
incomprehensible how someone who is not
cooperated with her mental health
evaluations can be released into our
community we possibly kid help you for
nine months
law enforcement in the public search for
then 14 year-old smart after she was
abducted from her Salt Lake City home in
2002 we have found Elizabeth smart and
that she is here and well and healthy
smart now 30 spoke about bars e2 Gayle
King in a CBS this morning podcast in
April
that what she was doing to me I mean I
felt like she was every bit as
responsible then you know more because
she had had children bar Z will be under
federal supervision for five years
following her release her attorney would
not comment on his clients mental health
but in a statement he said in part I
greatly appreciate that our Board of
Pardons is willing to reassess and
reconsider legal conclusions smarts
other captor Mitchell is serving two
life terms sentences for kidnapping and
sexually assaulting her yeah many of us
remember that Elizabeth Smart story and
how miraculous it was that she was found
alive she's now married she's got two
children very pregnant she's in her
eighth month right eighth month and the
last thing she needs is this type of
news her father said in the Utah desert
news that they are worried that bar Z
could come near yes before the children
yes it's scary very worried about that
thank you vibe